Let’s get one thing out of the way: water
fleas are not fleas.
For one, fleas are insects.
Water fleas are a subset of small crustaceans
called Cladocera.
There are over 600 known species of Cladocerans,
but scientists have estimated that there might
actually be around 2-4 times that number.
Water fleas got their name because not only
do they, you know, kind of resemble fleas,
they’ve also been known to jump like them.
And it’s kind of a strange experience to
see something that looks fairly familiar reconfigured
into the microcosmic.
If you look at Daphnia from the side, you
can see the definite flea-type shape that
informs their name.
But if you manage to look at one from the
top, well I could very easily lie to you and
say that this is a completely different organism,
and you would probably believe me.
Now, of course, we would never do that.
That’s not the kind of show this is.
Water fleas are large in microcosmos terms.
They range from around 0.5 mm to 6 mm long,
absolutely gigantic.
And they’ve got 10 sets of appendages distributed
around their body, including 2 different sets
of antennae.
One of those is for sensing, the other is
for swimming.
There's also an array of 5-6 limbs that form
a feeding and respiratory apparatus, as well
as a pair of claws at the end of their abdomen,
which they use as a filtering tool or for
defense.
What might be especially striking is that
one very large eye, something we don’t often
see in the microcosmos.
As embryos, Cladocerans have two brown eye
spots.
But in the last stage of their development,
the eyespots merge together to form one large
compound eye that will go on to help orient
them while they swim around.
Cladocerans also another small photosensitive
organ called the naupliar eye, which is located
between the compound eye and the mouth.
The water fleas we see most in our own journey
through the microcosmos are Daphnia, a genus
that includes more than a hundred species.
And while yes, daphnia are found in lakes,
they're also sold in aquarium stories because
fish love to eat them.
You might see bags of them, filled with hundreds
of daphnia.
As they get packed together, the oxygen around
them gets depleted.
Cladocerans use hemoglobin to transport oxygen,
and in situations like this, they can increase
the concentration of hemoglobin in their bodies
up to 20-fold to transport more oxygen.
And as that happens, you might actually see
those packs of daphnia become a much more
vivid red.
Here, you can see the Daphnia’s heart beating.
At 20 degrees Celsius, it’ll beat around
200 times a minute.
But that rate depends on the temperature,
it beats slower when the daphnia are in colder
conditions.
The heart rate will also change in the presence
of substances like alcohol and caffeine, but
we’re a little bit too nervous about hurting
our daphnia to demonstrate that.
Our daphnia often come from those aquarium
packs, rescued from their fate as fish-food
to live a less hazardous life in our own fish-free
pond aquarium.
They do occasionally get eaten by the hydras
in the tank, but it's a better chance of survival
compared with the alternative.
Daphnia and their cladoceran relatives are
filter feeders, gathering their food with
a filtering apparatus made of their limbs.
Key among these are their phyllopods, a set
of flat legs that resemble leaves.
The phyllopods create a water current that
flows from the front of the water flea towards
the back, allowing it to collect and consume
algae.
Here, you can see a Daphnia filtering a rotifer,
though the rotifer is quickly discarded probably because
it's probably a bit too big for easy consumption.
While daphnia are often transparent, you can
sometimes get hints of just what food is dominating
their diet by looking at the tinges of color
that line their body.
With more green algae, the daphnia will start
to look a little green or yellow.
And when they eat more bacteria, you might
see more of a white or salmon pink color.
Daphnia are, of course, often eaten.
So, they employ several strategies to avoid
predators, including the tried and true strategy
of just getting the heck out of the way.
Only when Daphnia do it, we call it diel vertical
migration.
During the day, when light is plentiful, they
stake out lower, darker depths where predators
are less able to see them.
During the night, they move upwards, able
to eat without fear of looming threats.
Daphnia arrange this diel vertical migration
around the presence of fish kairomones.
Kairomones are chemical signals that alert
them to the proximity of fish.
If they don't detect these signals, the Daphnia
might just spend the day hanging out towards
the surface so they can gather more food.
But kairomones don't just affect the Daphnia's
migration, they also affect the size of their offspring.
In the presence of fish kairomones, one daphnia
species has been observed birthing smaller
water fleas, a change in size that helps them
avoid detection.
Interestingly though, the presence of the
phantom midge, another predator, sets off
the opposite result: their kairomones will
make the Daphnia grow larger, presumably because
the midge prefers a smaller prey.
In response to the midge's kairomones, the
Daphnia have also been observed growing a
set of jagged edges on their head called "neck-teeth".
You know, all the usual protective measures,
growing extra large and having teeth on your neck.
Environmental cues also shape the reproduction
of Daphnia by directly affecting the sexual
composition of their population.
An adult female daphnia will usually go through
asexual reproduction, producing a clutch of
parthenogenetic eggs every time she molts.
The eggs go into her brood chamber, and after
about a day, they hatch.
The young larvae stay inside her brood chamber
for about 3 more days, emerging as young Daphnia
that are genetically identical to their mother.
With asexual reproduction, a female Daphnia
might produce a clutch every 3-4 days until
her death, producing more clones of herself
and rapidly increasing their population.
There are a few Daphnia species that are strictly
parthenogenetic.
But most follow a pattern called cyclic parthenogenesis, interrupting their asexual cycle for sexual reproduction.
This switch happens in response to environmental
cues signaling that times have gotten tough.
Maybe the population has become too dense
and their food has become scarce.
Or perhaps the days are getting shorter, the
temperatures lower, or the pond drier.
When these external danger signals are sensed,
some of the parthenogenetically-derived eggs
will start to hatch into males.
These male Daphnia are genetically identical
to their female brood mates, after all they
are parthenogenetically produced.
And that means that sex in daphnia is an environmentally determined trait.
There isn’t a genetic difference between
males and females, rather there’s some kind
of external signal that takes a genetically
identical population of daphnia and determines
whether some of them will become male.
Those males then reproduce with females from
other clutches, creating an opportunity for
true gene exchange.
Following sexual reproduction, the female
daphnia will produce a protective saddle-like
structure called an ephippium, which holds
two eggs called the resting eggs.
When the female molts, she will shed the ephippium
too.
It might sink to the bottom of the pond or
disperse through the water or with the wind.
And where it lands, it might rest for years.
It's only when the environment that surrounds
the egg signals favorable conditions that
they will hatch, producing females that will
soon proceed back to their normal parthenogenetic
reproduction schedule.
Nature is full of change.
Light, temperature, your neighbors--these
can alter dramatically over the course of
days, weeks, and years.
And so, the life of any organism, from the
smallest microbe to the largest whale, is
built on responding and adapting to the changes
around them.
Compared to many of their smaller neighbors,
water fleas don’t look like they would be
the most nimble in the face of existential
threat.
In our own footage, they often stand out like
awkward giants, straddling the thin line that
separates the world of the micro and macro.
How can an organism that doesn’t quite seem
to fit in either world contend with the challenges
of both?
Quite well, apparently.
It’s as if they have managed to make the
best of both worlds, mastering the reproductive
strategies of one while processing the signals
of the other.
Yes, it is true, water fleas may not be the
most elegant of the
creatures we see in the microcosmos.
But with a bag full of ingenious tricks, you
can’t deny that they’ve got style.
Thanks for coming on this journey with us
as we explore
the unseen world that surrounds us.
If you like this, well, that makes us really
happy.
And if you want to thank somebody, you can
thank us, but you can also thank all of the
people on this screen right now.
They are our patrons on Patreon.
They are the reason we are able to make this
fun show in these uncertain times of constant change.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James, check out Jam & Germs
on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, we are
at youtube.com/micrcosmos